She addresses why she's crying in a,
like, a current TMZ article.
She was crying because the men were disrespectful.
Well, in the TMZ interview she did,
she explains that she's crying because,
like, immediately after that,
she was, like,
still in the shower when the documentary crew was coming up and, like,
posted up in the living room waiting for her.
So she didn't get, like,
even 30 seconds to breathe.
She came out and was like,
oh, hey. Um.
And immediately had to start answering questions.
And then he was there for, like,
an hour in her face, and she was like, yeah,
it's overwhelming. It's overwhelming, but.
And even when she's crying,
she's more crying cause she's like, gosh,
I really, you know,
these men have supported me all these years,
and I promised them a certain experience,
and I'm kind of sad that it wasn't the way that I wanted.
She's not crying cause she's hurt, sad, traumatized.
She's crying cause this is her fantasy
that didn't go the way that she planned and how she wanted,
and a lot of the men were disrespectful.
They were giving her a guilt trip and making her feel even worse.
So that's why she was crying,
because of their disrespect
and the way that it kind of ruined the fantasy for her.
But all in all, she was doing the 100 to prepare for doing the thousand,
because, like,
in a couple days, she's doing 300.
She's just Like, ramping up.
She super, super duper enjoys it.
She has an amazing relationship with her family.
Like, she talks to her mom every day.
She's an amazing businesswoman.
She has, like,
eight or nine employees and is looking for more.
Like, she's good. She's.
She's more than good. Like,
I can only wish my children are that happy and successful
at the shit that they wanna do in life.